let's go to Cassidy who's got A.D
just a dominant performance and a
closeout win which you got to soak in in
that entire fourth quarter and how do
you describe how you guys came out and
performed throughout this one uh we know
closeout games are the toughest there's
a tough team right there all eight guys
Playmakers Elite scores and we let one
go in Memphis
um came out kind of flat obviously
they're at home playing with a sense of
desperation and we're at home you know
we came up with that energy our crowd
was in short but we came out with a
sister urgency that we're not going to
let them guys come in here and force it
game seven and it's a long flight so we
didn't want to take that fight again but
um you know we just came up with that
mindset of internet today and your
defensive presence was a big reason why
you had 26 blocks in this series that's
the most blocks in a series by a Lakers
player since shaft
how do you describe just your defensive
mentality and and how you were able to
change this series
just competing you know I just try to
compete
um protect my guys I know that they like
to pressure up on the ball you got a guy
who can drive to the back anytime he
wanted a job Jaren Jackson in the post
um Baines get to the basket and I just
want to protect them you know protect
their room and Ultra shots and
um I was able to block some and get our
energy going on the defensive end maybe
after starting off the season two in ten
13th Place at the All-Star break to now
getting your first playoff series with
in front of these Lakers fans I know you
guys haven't gotten this far just to
come this far but what is this win mean
to you oh it means a lot like you said
the way we started two and ten and then
we were able to move up a little bit in
the playoffs get a trade and then kind
of just go up hill from there
um but it doesn't stop here we're not
satisfied you know we're happy that
we're able to get to the second round
but we're not satisfied we gotta put we
got a lot of work to do
um leaving the rebound and transition
especially with the two teams that if we
could possibly pay um they'd like to get
out and transition I think it's two to
three bar really well so we got a lot of
work to do but we're gonna enjoy this
one tonight and get ready for
see who we play on Sunday see we play on
Sunday so uh we've got a couple days to
enjoy let our body right into the
physical series
um but it was fun it was fun to compete
against those guys enjoy Rusty and
sitting on the couch watching that game
on Sunday congrats on the win
[Music]